Du bist die Qual, ich war schon immer Masochist. Du bist das Geld, ich geb dich aus, es lohnt sich nicht. Du bist die Welt, wo Atem nicht gefangen hält. Ich lebe, weil du ich gefangen hätte.
Ich lebe, weil du mein Atem bist, bin müde, weil du mein Kissen bist, bin durstig, weil du dein Wasser bist, du bist für mich mein zweites Ich. Ich lebe, bin müde, bin durstig, du bist für mich mein zweites Ich. Aber ich finde gut, dass es so eine überpronounced Version jetzt war. Sowas wie Websites, die auch in einfacher Sprache manchmal erscheinen. So Government-Seiten, die man in einfacher Sprache anklicken kann. Ja, so dieser Künstler, der merkt, dass die Zuschauer den Song nicht verstehen. Über den Wolken muss die Freiheit wohl grenzenlos sein. Und man versteht selber nichts, grossartig. Vielen, vielen Dank an Christina, die dieses Intro geschickt hat. Moment, ich glaube, da ist ein Scherz. Nein, kleiner Gag. Max natürlich hat das Ganze geschickt, vielen Dank an Max. Und ja, vielleicht mittlerweile mit ein wenig Reifung können wir diesen Text verstehen und entziffern. Entschüsseln? Ehrlich gesagt nicht, weil ich glaube, falsche Lyrik kann man auch nicht ... Eine Gleichung, die falsch ist, kann man auch nicht auflösen. Komm mal, da ist doch mal der Tessert, Stefan! Hallo! Ich habe ausgeschlafen. Das könnte auch ein Song sein. Du bist ausgeschlafen, ich merk's, du hast dir schon die Decke umgelegt. Ich bin fit, ich bin ausgeschlafen. Du bist gemütlich. Ich komme mit meinen Mathe-Gleichungen um die Ecke. Wie geht's dir? Mir geht's gut. Mir geht's sehr, sehr gut. Ich finde die Idee gut, dass Künstler ihren Song falsch verstanden haben. So wie Christina Stürmer, die das noch mal erklären muss, noch mal ein Statement macht, vielleicht so ein blaues Reklambüchlein noch mal so rausbringt, so ein Lektürenschlüssel, so eine Gegendarstellung noch mal so darstellt. Ja, ja. Es ist ein bisschen wie Stand-up-Comedians auf der Bühne, die diese Kennt ihr das, Kennt ihr das Gags machen. Ja. Und wo Leute, kann ich mir vorstellen, manchmal auch sagen, nee, nee, habe ich nicht. Weil oft ist ja eine Beobachtung an sich, die man, weiß nicht, festgestellt hat und man ist jetzt der Erste, der das sagt. Ja. Ja, krass, macht ihr das auch in die Dusche pinkeln? Oh, da hab ich noch nie mit jemandem drüber gesprochen, aber ja, ich pinke auch immer in die Dusche, so was. Dann stell ich mir mal vor, wie jemand was ganz Weirdes sagt, und dann sagen die Leute, nee, niemand lacht, es ist stilles, alle gucken sich an und sagen, nee ... Wie jetzt gerade alle sagen, wie oft wechselt ihr eigentlich eure Bettlaken, wann wascht ihr? Das ist aktuell Thema, ich schaue ja keine Nachrichten mehr, aber das ist anscheinend. Mein Name ist Stefan Tietze, herzlich willkommen zu den Tagesteamthemen Schlafzimmer. Die Deutschen waschen zu selten ihre Bettdecken und Bettlaken.
Empfohlen hier von der Verbraucherzentrale ist mindestens alle zwei Wochen.
Die Deutschen neigen eher dazu, alle sechs bis acht Wochen ihre Bettlaken zu tauschen.
Berlin, Sigmar Gabriel zieht um. Er hat eine schmucke Maisonett-Wohnung gefunden in Berlin-Kreuzbach. Wir schalten direkt vor Ort. Sigmar Gabriel ist der letzte Politiker, der dir einfällt. Da merkt man genau, wann du das Tagesgestehen verlassen hast. Das habe ich gerade auch gedacht. Ich habe auch gedacht, es fällt sehr negativ auf mich zurück. Aber zu meiner Verteidigung, ich habe gerade bei Twitter so eine Liste gesehen mit Korruptionsfällen in den letzten, weiß ich nicht wie vielen Jahren. Sigmar auf eins? Nee, und Sigmar war mittendrin, aber war der einzige Rote und es sah aus, als wäre er markiert worden als besonderer Fall, aber er war einfach das einzige Mitglied aus der SPD. Alle anderen waren halt schwarz, weil CDU oder CSU Mitglieder waren. Aber deswegen war das, ich habe gerade vor der
Aufzeichnung gerade noch diese Korruptionsliste
gesehen. Ich will jetzt kurz um das Tagesgeschehen.
Weißt du, ich gucke mir Korrektivsachen an.
Du schaust alles, was in Listen leicht
konsumierbar ist, drückst du dir rein. Aber ich
finde es gut, da kann man sehen.
Im Hintergrund arbeite ich die ganze Zeit an so einem
Kuh, an so einem Politik-Kuh.
Ich will irgendwas aufdecken.
Du willst putschen.
Ich will putschen, ohne genau zu wissen, wie oder was genau das ist. Das klingt schon mal gut. Aber ich arbeite seit mehreren Folgen jetzt schon daran, dass man irgendwann mal so ein Investitiv-Coup, deswegen gucke ich mir so Statistiken an und deswegen Sigmar Gabriel. Ja, wo fängt man an? Was ist der erste Tab, den man aufmacht? Was ist der erste Tab für einen Putsch? Skandal. Oder Skandal-Google. Gerüchte, finde ich. Gerüchte. Gibt es Gerüchte, die ich ausnutzen kann. Aber ich finde, man sieht daran gut, wo du ausgestiegen bist. Genauso wie wenn Leute ein Pokémon nennen, kann man auch genau sehen, wo in der Reihe man gerade ist. Wann ist man ausgeschieden, wann nicht? Ist Hoggepi noch dabei oder geht es dann nur um Glumander oder so? Dann weißt du genau, wo die Leute sind. Aber auch schwierig. Und bei dir ist es auch, Sigmar Gabriel, man weiss genau, ah, du bist in Feuerrot ausgestiegen aus der deutschen Politik. Aber kommen nicht die ersten 150 immer wieder zurück, auch wieder in so Retro? Ich glaube nicht, nee, also ich habe die vermisst tatsächlich ein bisschen. Aber die haben dann teilweise noch weitere Vorentwicklungen, Nachentwicklungen und so. Und das hat dann aber niemand gewusst. Ja. Das waren die Pokémon-News von Florentin. Das hat aber dann niemand gewusst. Naja, das könnte ich dir jetzt natürlich nochmal aufdröseln, ganz genau, aber sicher bin ich mir auch nicht. Okay, aber Putsch, erster Tab, Gerüchte.de, du willst mal gucken, was fliegen so für Gerüchte rum, damit du Leute packen kannst. Genau, Klammer zu. Jetzt, da waren wir bei dem Bettdecken-Ding, Klammer zu. Ja. Wir waren bei dem Stand-Up. Zwei Wochen sagst du. Bei dem Stand-Up. Zwei Wochen Bettdecken. Genau, und ich glaube, manchmal sagt man Dinge, als Comedian kann man das testen. Als Musiker oder Musikerin, glaube ich, merkst du erst, wenn das Lied schon lange aufgenommen ist, dass es gar keinen Sinn ergibt. Du hast ja nur die drei Leute im Tonstudio.
Das ist eigentlich dein ganzes Publikum und was die cool finden, dominiert das ganze Album.
Ja, aber die bezahlt man ja auch als, keine Ahnung, Sänger.
99 Problems, ja, okay.
Und dann kommt das Album raus und niemand versteht das.
Was meinst du?
Du hast 99 Probleme.
Willst du nicht irgendwie Hilfe suchen oder so?
Nein, nein, ich meine, nee, das ist ein buddhistisches Sprichwort. Es sind schon viele Probleme. Ja, aber... Zählst du, die hast du ja alle aufgezählt, oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Nein, nein, das ist jetzt nur so ein Spruch, das ist halt 99, das passt immer gut, das ist so wie 101 Dalmatiner. Weil du kannst ruhig mit mir reden, ich hätte dir gesagt, dass du mit mir reden kannst. Nein, nein, nein, guck, pass auf, die hat auch nicht genau 101 Dalmatiner. Ich glaube, die hat schon 101 Dalmatiner. Nein, das ist einfach eine Zahl. Nee, nee, man sieht auch, den Poster habe ich immer nachgezählt. Hast du die Nach... Quatsch, so viele Hunde passen gar nicht auf den Poster. Oin, Gloin, Balin, Merlin, Boin, Boin, Oin, Soim, Floin. Autor sein ist nicht leicht. Oder Tausend und eine Nacht, das ist auch nicht genau Tausend und eine Nacht. Nee, auch da habe ich nachgezählt. Nein, das ist einfach... Ich habe den Film mehrere Mal geschaut und es sind wirklich Tausend und eine Nächte. Es gibt einfach coolere Zahlen als andere, deswegen 99 Probleme. Ich kann jetzt wirklich mit uns reden, weil ich habe, also Marianne und ich wollen dich gerne einladen oder zum Abendessen. Ich habe mich als Jay-Z schon sehr gefreut über die Einladung von Marianne und Uwe und wirklich, euer Kartoffelsaat war köstlich, aber es ist nett. Ihr müsst euch nicht so sehr um mich kümmern. Die Idee ist ja, a bitch ain't one, also ich habe keine Probleme mit Bitches. Genau, ja, ja, aber du kannst auch mit Bitches über uns reden. Das ist nett, aber nein, wie gesagt, ich habe vielleicht, wenn es so kommt. Okay, cool. Wer fragt Jay-Z, wie es ihm geht? Ja, das stimmt schon, aber ich hab vielleicht vier Probleme. Vier Probleme. Wie wär's damit ... I got four problems, but ... Aber guck mal, das passt gar nicht mehr rein, Uwe. Das passt gar nicht mehr in den Rhythmus rein. Aber ich finde die Botschaft ist besser. Ja, aber du musst ja bei Rap immer gucken, dass es reinpasst in den Takt. So, ne? Okay. Lass vielleicht diese Rap-Sachen dann eher bei mir so.
Das ist dann eher meine Kompetenz.
Alles klar.
Gut.
Aber was ist, wenn man zwei Bettdecken hat?
Eine ist oben und eine ist unten.
Und du willst die rotieren?
Und die rotiert man.
Also, erhöht das die Dauer oder nicht? Das Problem ist bei mir ich schlafe ja in mehreren Betten, sag ich mal. Und ich sag mal so, wenn du in fünf Betten jede Woche eineinhalb Nächte schläfst, wie, da musst du nochmal umrechnen auf, weil es zählt ja nur Schlafene. Aber die vielen Frauen, in deren Betten du schläfst, da geht es ja auch schon darum, wie oft die das dann waschen. Nee, ja gut, da wechsle ich die Frauen, nicht die Betten. Die Kettensäge holt da raus, warum auch immer. Niemand versteht diese Reppe. Aber es geht ja schon um drin geschlafene Nächte. Also das ist ja nicht so, wenn ich da einmal drin schlafe und dann drei Wochen später, dann ist die faul geworden. Wenn du in der Nacht in den Hamptons schläfst, zählt die Nacht nicht für dein New York Townhouse. Okay, und das ist bei mir das Problem, da falle ich natürlich raus aus der Zählung, weil ich natürlich immer unterschiedliche Betten habe, in den unterschiedlichen Decken und ich habe immer die Lasagnentaktik. Genau, was ich dir jetzt mal vorwerfe, ist, so doll wie ich es schon überziehe, obwohl ich immer in meinem eigenen Bett schlafe, like an Idiot, wie ein totaler Peasant-Anfänger, glaube ich, du übertreibst es nochmal. Weil ich glaube, unsere Grenze, wo wir sagen, jetzt ist es vorbei, jetzt wechseln wir das, ist ähnlich. Das heißt, ich glaube, du wechselst dann nach drei Jahren. Absolut, so ab einem gewissen Punkt kann es ja nicht mehr schlimmer werden. Ich denke mir so, es gibt ja einen Punkt, es wird ja nicht immer, immer, immer schlimmer. Es wird auch sogar besser. Ab einem gewissen Punkt ist es okay und dann wird es vielleicht sogar besser, ja. Wenn man Probleme sehr lange aussitzt, merkt man, manchmal lösen sie sich von selber. Und manchmal sogar, in gar nicht so seltenen Fällen, wird es besser. Ja. Weil zum Beispiel habe ich mal irgendwo im Fernsehen, glaube ich, so eine Dokumentation über jemanden, der aufgehört hat zu duschen. Und es wurde halt sein Körperduft, Odor, wurde peu a peu schlechter. Schlechter, schlechter, schlechter. Ja. Irgendwann hat sich aber, weil der Körper ist es nicht mehr gewohnt und der Bakterienhaushalt ist verwirrt und sowas. Irgendwann ist es aber normal. Und irgendwann kommen damit klar. Hä? Irgendwann kommen die Bakterien damit klar und finden das dann okay und können sich diese neue Situation, können sich die Situation annehmen. Haben sie zusammengesetzt, haben Situation Room gebildet. Ja, die Verwirrung wurde Stück für Stück aufgelöst. Ja, die Verwirrung wurde Stück für Stück aufgelöst. Aufgelöst, Verwirrung. Sorry, sorry, einmal noch mal für mich. Wir kriegen das denn. Nämlich das Exper-Team ... Sorry, kannst du es einmal noch mal für mich erklären? Ihr seid verwirrt. Einmal noch mal für mich erklären, sorry. Ich glaube, ich habe ... Er duscht sich nicht mehr. Er duscht sich nicht mehr. Wir kommen damit klar. Ja, wir haben dieses Experten-Team. Sorry, ich bring komplett raus. Ich sehe schon einiges an Nicken im Raum, aber bei mir hat es noch überhaupt nicht Klick gemacht. Ihr seid verliert. Die haben dieses Rollenspiel vorbereitet, um euch zu zeigen, wie wir uns darauf einstellen.
Okay, gut, dann, okay.
Für die letzte Reihe.
Mit Handpuppen.
Okay.
Und dann löst sich jemand diese Verwirrung unter den Bakterien auf und die kriegen es hin, das in den Griff zu bekommen.
Und dann wird das neutralisiert und irgendwann wurde es sogar als positiv wahrgenommen, dieser Geruch.
Weil irgendwann war es dann einfach normaler, menschlicher Geruch.
Und das ist genau dieser Punkt, wo sich Faulheit belohnt.
Wie viele menschliche Entdeckungen sind passiert, nur wenn Menschen faul waren?
Käse.
Milch, Milch, schlechte Milch, Käse.
Ja.
Traubensaft, Traubensaft, schlechter Traubensaft, Wein plötzlich.
Bei Käse hat man es wahnsinnig strapaziert, finde ich.
Oh ja. Also bei Milch stehen lassen,  öch, öch, öch, öch, öch, öch, öch, öch, öch, öch, öch, alle mal in der Gesellschaft Blauschimmelkäse auch noch mal stehen lassen? Lass uns einfach noch mal stehen. Mal gucken, wie weit es geht. Nicht aufessen, aber es ist so köstlich, dass man sich wirklich zurückhalten muss. Aber was passiert, wenn es weitergeht? Oder was ist, wenn Wein einfach, na gut, der Wein bleibt immer Wein, da ist dann auch schon. Es wird dann irgendwann Konjakt. Das ist der Punkt. Wirklich? Irgendwann ist ja noch Schluss. Nein, also es wird, ja genau, aber genau, es wird nicht aus Wein, irgendwann wird auch Essig, ehrlich gesagt. Wein wird Essig werden. Das scheint eine aufregende Bahn zu sein, wenn du so eine Traube bist und denkst dir, eines Tages, was werde ich werden? Manche werden als Weintrauben gegessen, andere werden Rosinen, andere werden dann Traubensaft und dann werden manche als Traubensaft schon getrunken. Also es wird immer dünner, es wird immer weniger.
Bitte, ich will nicht in Durstlöscher, ich will nicht in fucking Durstlöscher sein, ich will nicht in fucking Durstlöscher sein, ich will in fucking, ich will jetzt in Chateau Petrus sein. Bitte nicht, das Lila nimmt zwei Kaubonbon. Oder so Powerade. Nee, bitte nicht Powerade.
Und immer mehr Weintrauben biegen so ab, so wie so eine Abschlussklasse.
Ein paar Leute haben noch Kontakt, aber andere biegen schon ab,
die gehen schon in Fruchtlöscher-Business, aber manche bleiben sich noch treu, bis sie am Ende dann Wein und Cognac werden und man sagen so, ja gut, die anderen sind auf dem Weg abgefahren. Ganz kurz, ich weiss, das ist ein Scherz, wenn man Comedy-Podcast oder sowas, aber hast du das Gefühl, dass die Durstlöchertrauben auch so an einer Mosel oben auf so einem Weinwerk stehen?
Ja, absolut. Das ist schon eine Vorstellung. Der perfekte Hagen Günther Jauch streift sie noch mal zart mit seiner Hand noch mal an und sagt, die sind richtig. Die Caprisonnenfrüchte werden genau da auch gemacht. Ja, sicher. Du glaubst, dass in Caprison überhaupt schon mal eine Frucht gesehen hat? Das glaubst du wirklich? Ja, absolut, natürlich. Klar, da ist der, der Weinberg, der ist der Weinberg, naja, er sagt, ja gut, das geht hier alles schön in Fruchtiger und hier hinten, der Südhang, das ist ja alles Lila Mauams, also das geht alles direkt in die Mauernproduktion. Und da bist du so ein Einkäufer für Mauern, der dann auch so wirklich zu den ganzen Bauern in die Bretagne fährt. Und ich stelle mir so vor, wie er so gleitet mit seinen Fingern so über die Gerstenkörner und sowas. Das wäre doch mal geil, oder? Wenn so Mauerm so eine Werbung machen würde, wo man so richtig so auf High-Quality-Luxus geht und so sonnengeschwängerte Hügel und dann wirklich so ein Bauer mit so einem Strohut streift durch die Trauben und am Ende Mawam. Ne, wenn er so, was wollt ihr, dann sagt der Professor in so einem Chesterfield-Sessel, der sagt Mawam, dafür stehe ich mit meinem Namen. Finde ich richtig gut. Herbert Mawam, Professor Herbert Mawam, Mawam. Aber fände ich auch mal geil, so eine Werbung machen, die so gar nicht vom Stil dazu passt. Imagefilm. Und sie einfach denkt, was? Imagefilm. Wir haben die besten, die absolut, die absolut besten Zuckerrüben für sie angebaut. In Norditalien. So eine klassische Musik, die dann unter die Sonne, die reinscheintint, man sieht dann so die Zuckerrüben wachsen. Die Zuckerrüben fallen so in Slow-Mo und so das Kondenswasser stösst so von ihnen ab und sie fliegen durch die Luft. Dann die Mitarbeiter alle mega, mega schick, aber auch in so Schutzkleidung und Haartücher und so riechen dran und so. Ja, ja. Und so ein kleiner sizilianischer Bauer ist Junge, kriegt dann am Ende in die Hand Fritt. Petz und Fritt. Petz-Spender. Ja. Und die ganze Reise hat sich am Ende gelohnt. Petz. Finde ich fantastisch. Nee, aber es sind die Trauben, die du am Weinberg siehst, kann man quasi nicht essen. Es sind keine Esstrauben. Es gibt immer die Trauben. Und wer hält mich davon ab, die zu essen? Du kannst die essen, das passiert auch nicht. Sagt man das nur, damit niemand die isst, weil die sind ja nicht geschützt. Das ungefälligste Pestizid ist Unwissenheit. Ja, weil du könntest ja einfach mit deinen Kumpels hingehen und alle Weintrauben aufessen. Man könnte mit seinem Umfeld. Dann hätte Und dann hätte Wein Deutschland ein Problem, weil ich mir den Bauch vollgeschlagen habe. Genau, mit riesigen Trauben. Mit den schlecht schmeckenden Trauben. Genau. Schmecken, glaube ich, scheiße, sind, glaube ich, nicht gefährlich, aber du kannst theoretisch einfach hingehen und die essen, aber es sind nicht die Trauben, die wir im Supermarkt essen. Aber das heißt, das ist so ein bisschen die Geschichte vom hässlichen Träublein. Man könnte sagen, angenommen, dein Kind ist potthässlich, wirklich grottenhässlich, also wirklich eine Null von zehn. Ja, null. Wirklich eine Null von zehn. Die Skala fängt bei eins an. Und das Kind sagt, warum bin ich so hässlich? Und dann könnte man entweder das hässliche Entlein machen, was, finde ich, ein bisschen eine komische Geschichte ist, weil es werden ja alle Enten Schwäne. Also ... Enten werden Schwäne, ganz kurz, ganz kurz, ganz kurz. Moment, das hässliche Enten. Sie haben gerade gesagt, bei der Pressekonferenz, in der es um ihren Korruptionsskandal geht, Herr Gabriel, haben Sie gesagt, alle Enten werden zu Schwänen. Das sind, ich habe die Aussagen jetzt nicht vor Augen, da müsste ich jetzt noch mal ins Archiv gehen und da noch mal Rücksprache halten. Sie haben gerade gesagt, alle Enten werden zu Schwänen. Ich kann, also die Zeit. Wir haben 538 E-Mails gefunden, wie Sie an diverse Mitarbeiter, Mitarbeiterinnen den Satz, alle Enten werden zu Schwänen schreiben. Das muss ein Witz gewesen sein. Ich erinnere mich jetzt an die konkrete
Aussage. Ich schreibe sehr viele Mails, wie sie
wahrscheinlich herausgefunden haben. Kennen Sie Ihre
Kollegin Gesine Schwan?
Ich
habe aktuell keine
Erinnerung. Sie
ist eine Kollegin von Ihnen.
Ach so, ich dachte, Sie meinen jetzt
Gesine. Ach so, jetzt verstehe ich, wie Sie meinen. Da habe ich falsch verstanden die Frage. Sie haben sie in mehreren E-Mails als hässliches Endlein beschimpft. Finden Sie, das ist eine angemessene Firmenpolitik? Das ist ein freundlicher Umgangston, ich kenne sie schon lange. Weil eines Tages wird sie ja ein Schwan. Also, aber das ist doch hässliches Endlein. Oder am Ende wirst du ein schöner Schwan. Aber mein Problem mit der Geschichte hässliches Entlein ist, dass ja alle Entlein hässlich sind. Kannst du uns alle kurz nochmal reinholen in die Geschichte? Es gibt einen Wurf, es gibt einen grossen Wurf. Es gibt einen Entlein. Es gibt einen Entlein. Und das Entlein sagt, was bin ich so hässsslich und dann sagt die Mutter, pass auf, pass up, eines Tages bist du ein schöner Schwan. Und dann eines Tages ist das ein schöner Schwan geworden und dann sagt das Entlein, ja wunderbar, jetzt fangen wir an. Und da ist das Problem, du hast ja nur ein Problem, wenn dein Kind hässlicher ist als andere Kinder. Genau.
Weil wenn alle Kinder hässlich wären, so wie es beim hässlichen Entlein impliziert wird, gäbe es ja kein Problem, weil das Kind vergleicht sich ja nicht mit Erwachsenen und sagt, oh, irgendwie die und die ist so schön, sondern du vergleichtst dich mit seinen anderen Mitschülerinnen und Mitschülern und sagst, warum bin ich so fucking hässlich? Und wenn du sagst, hässliches Entlein, sagst du ja, aber warum sind die anderen Entleinen denn nicht hässlich?
Und deswegen würde ich sagen, lass uns diese Fabel doch einfach ersetzen durch das köstliche Träublein. Weil du sagst, ja pass auf, es gibt die Trauben, die sind so schon süss, aber die werden alle ganz schnell aufgegessen. Da wachsen die süssen Trauben nicht nur mit anderen süssen Trauben auf und merken deswegen gar nicht, dass sie anders sind. Ja, gut, die botanischen Feinheiten. Aber ich muss es ja zeichnen, ich muss es ja konkret zeichnen. Zeichnen sie einfach zwei Trauben an derselben Rebe und eines ist süss und dann können sie das so mit stolz geschwellter Brust und ich bin die süste Traube und die andere können sie so ein bisschen schrumpelig sauer. Und dann kommt aber der Mauermfabrikant Otto Mauerm und pflückt aber schon die süssen weg, weil das sind die besten, die pflücken wir weg. Und die saure Traube, die kleine, die saure Traube, die wird erst langfristig zum köstlichen Wein und gewinnt den Weinpreis. So, im Sinne von, wer am Anfang nicht gut dasteht, hat später es besser. Das köstliche Träublein. Sie stellen so viele Rückfragen. Das köstliche Träublein. Finde ich absolut fantastisch. Ja, finde ich viel besser. Schreib das doch mal. Ich will, dass du so eine Kinderbuch-Trilogie hast. Von Hüsterich und Schnieferinchen. Genau, das köstliche Träublein und jetzt, genau, to be announced. Und Schaft. Und das dann ... Schaft, der Vampirjäger. Schaft. Schaft. Okay. Nee, möchte ich jetzt nicht ... S-C-H-A-F-T. Schaft. Okay, ähm ... Das ist noch in der Anfangsphase, da ist die Säule noch nicht ganz, aber es wird intensiv. Worum geht's? Hüsterich und Schneeferinchen, das köstliche Träublein schafft. Auch nicht der schafft oder einfach nur schafft. Okay? Ich bin gut, von dem Macher von Hüsterich und Schneeferinchen und das köstliche Träublein kommt jetzt der Sexskandal in Reutlingen oder sowas. Du machst so einen Thriller. Ich glaube, es ist super schwer, aus so einer Kinderecke wieder rauszukommen. Naja, sehr einfach mit dem Sexskandal aus Reutlingen. Ja gut, das stimmt. Aber jetzt Rolf Zukowski, wenn der jetzt mal wirklich so ein Hip-Hop-Album rausbringt oder irgendwie so ein Death-Metal-Album. Ich glaube, der kommt da nicht mehr raus. Ich habe neunundennig Probleme. Aber Kinder sind keins. Aber Kinder sind keins. Aber Kinder haben keins. So, er versucht, sich wieder abzuspalten. Ist nicht so einfach, gerade für dich als Kinderbuchautor. Aber ich finde es gut, wenn diese Trilogie so einen Namen bekommt. Ach ja. Wenn die so ein ... Das Florentin-Wedel-Legendarium. Ja, genau. Einfach so ein literaturwissenschaftlicher Begriff, der einfach viel zu hoch ist. Eben, du bist nie über zehn Seiten gekommen, es ist grauenhaft gezeichnet. Hauptsächlich Fehler. Kinder verstehen diese grosse Story-Lücken in einer sehr einfachen Geschichte. Was ich aber machen würde, ist Duftreibeflächen. Beim köstlichen Träublein, da würde ich Duftreibeflächen machen. Bei Hüsterich und Schniefränchen explizit nicht, weil das Kind ist ja krank. Wenn man dem Kind das vorliest, dann riecht ja nichts. Ich sehe das jetzt schon auf so gebraucht, auf so Flohmärkten, wo Leute so ihre gebrauchten Bücher verkaufen, sehe ich jetzt schon diese abgegrabbelten Ekelbücher von dir. Ich sehe es jetzt schon so am Strassenrand in so einer Papierbox einfach so zu verschenken. Und dann ist es so ein bisschen angenieselt, ja, abgerieben, angenieselt und das Kind hat viermal draufgeniesst. Dreimal draufgeniesst, ja. Weil was du nicht verschenken willst, ist Hysterich und Schnieferinchen, wo das Kind definitiv draufgerotzt und draufgeniesst hat. Genau. Das willst du nicht verkaufen. Das kommt man immer raus, wenn das Kind krank ist. Ja. Und dann hast du auch noch diese Reibe-Duft-Scheisse da dran gemacht. Wobei das für mich als Autor ja perfekt perfekt ist. Du willst ja Produkte schaffen, die du nicht weiterverkaufen kannst,
sondern du musst immer Neues kaufen.
Und gerade so Krankheitsbücher sind auch perfekt,
weil du willst immer Neues kaufen,
weil du willst nicht die Bazillen von anderen Kindern.
Warum nicht ein Buch, was sich auflöst beim ersten Mal lesen?
Weil die Dauer, die du brauchst, um die Seiten zu lesen,
das Licht, was du dem aussetzt, müsste dann dafür sorgen, dass die Buchstaben verschwinden, diese Zaubertinte. Ja, und das ist dann so eine Plastikfolie eingeschweißt, und du musst es aufreissen, und dann hast du den Count. Ein Buch, das du nur einmal lesen kannst. Und nicht weitervergeben kannst, sondern musst du es immer kaufen. Finde ich gar nicht so dumm. Okay, weirdly negativ geframed. Ich finde es gar nicht so bestreuer dumm.
Es ist ungewohnt gute Idee, finde ich.
Es ist nicht so dumm wie die anderen Sachen, die du sonst immer sagst.
Ja, genau. Du kannst nicht mehr auf die Idee konzentrieren,
als auf alles andere niederzumachen.
Dann müsste man das mit Sarsch.
Aber das Problem ist halt die Frage,
ob das mit der Aufmerksamkeit auf Kerser aufmars, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam,
aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam,
aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, aufkehrsam, jetzt ist es weg, jetzt ist weg, jetzt ist weg, jetzt ist weg, jetzt ist es weg, jetzt Ohne Witz, jetzt, ich weiss, das sage ich oft, aber du musst jetzt bitte kurz herkommen, weil das ist sonst weg und dann kannst du es nie wieder lesen.
Ja, toll, jetzt ist es weg, toll, toll Witz, ich weiss, das sage ich oft, aber du musst jetzt bitte kurz herkommen,
weil das ist sonst weg und dann kannst du es nie wieder lesen.
Toll gemacht, Tim, super gemacht.
Weißt du was, komm mal, Herr Tim.
Und dann bricht er so Familienstreits aus,
weil der Vater mit dem Wutproblem kriegt dann,
der Vater mit dem Aggressionsproblem kriegt dann dieses Buch in die Hand,
wo Tim muss funktionieren. Tim muss im Moment funktionieren. Schreckliche Mischung. Und dann wirst du deswegen gecancelt als Kinderbuchautor. Aber finde ich schon gut, dass man dann dem Kind sagt, pass auf, das ist ein besonderes Buch, wenn du bereit bist. Also ich würde es so dem Kind sagen, wenn du bereit bist, komm zu mir. Ich will dir das jetzt gar nicht aufdrücken, sondern wenn du das Gefühl hast, du hast jetzt mal eine halbe Stunde, dann komm zu mir und dann machen wir das. Unsere pädagogische Pädagogik hasse ich jetzt schon. Aber dann so und wenn nicht, dann nicht. Ich will dich jetzt sagen, das gar nicht nerven, aber an sich finde ich das eine schöne Idee. Herr Will, nach Ihrem Buch Hysterich und Schnieferinchen, ein tolles Kinderbuch übrigens. Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Im zweiten Buch, das Köstliche Träublein, haben sie jetzt Heisse Nächte in Palermo, auf den Markt gebracht.
Ich gebe dazu, meine Tochter war verwirrt und wollte, hat sich natürlich gefreut auf den neuen Will.
Aber jetzt traue ich mich natürlich nicht so ganz, das Buch zu kaufen.
Ja, es soll so ein bisschen die Themen Liebe und Erotik auf kindische, spielerische Weise.
Es ist für Kinder gedacht.
Ja, es ist für Kinder gedacht.
Auf dem Cover sind zwei nackte Menschen.
Ja, genau.
Heisse Nächte in Palermo.
Richtig.
Ich möchte einfach dieses Buch nicht kaufen.
Gut, das ist natürlich ihre Entscheidung.
Aber es sind natürlich witzige Figuren,
Hüsterich und Fickerinchen.
Und ich glaube, das geht auch in die richtige Richtung. Schwänzerich und Fickerinchen. Kockerich. Wissen Sie, hören Sie mal zu. Man muss Kinder an die Hand nehmen und auch die Entwicklung weiterführen. Ja, ich bin so ein bisschen auf die Zwölf. Kockerich und Fickerinchen. Ich möchte nicht, dass meine Tochter mit diesen Begriffen aufwächst. Naja, das Gute ist ja, dass wenn ihr Kind das nicht aushält, dann ist das Buch weg. Wieso? Das Buch verschwindet, die Seiten lösen sich auf, weil es ist ja immer ein bisschen Feuchtigkeit in der Luft. Spüren Sie es gerade nicht, aber es ist immer ein bisschen Feuchtigkeit da. Eigentlich sind wir mehr Fische. Menschen sind mehr Fische, weil wir leben nicht nur... Ist Ihnen der Erfolg zu Kopf gestiegen? Ist Ihnen der Erfolg nach Österreich im Spiel? Schauen Sie mal, schauen Sie mal, schauen Sie mal, schauen Sie mal. Im Wasser ist weniger Sauerstoff, als Wasser in der Luft ist. Das heißt, wir sind mehr Fisch, als die Fische Mensch sind, weil da ist nicht so viel Sauerstoff. Und das heisst, ich habe natürlich jetzt Papier drucken lassen, das sich auflöst durch dieses Wasser. Und dadurch müssen sie natürlich auch eine gewisse Dringlichkeit an das Kind heranbringen. Ich schätze, das ist die ganze Zeit, die wir haben mit Flontanville, Kinderbuchautor, gleich gibt's mehr von meinem Interview mit Sigmar Gabriel.
Man könnte auch die Luft trinken. Luft trinken? Es gibt ja diese Luftentfeuchte, hatte ich lange, lange, lange, lange Jahre in meinem Kinderstube. Und da wurde immer, und das war für mich magisch, Wasser aus der Luft rausgesaugt und mir dann köstlich präsentiert, Darf man aber auf gar keinen Fall trinken, Kondenswasser, weil das zwirbelt dich komplett zusammen. Zu krass. Das ist immer so, wenn du auch deinem Kind erklären musst, dass man was nicht machen darf, aber du weißt nicht genau, warum. Zwirbelt dich. Pass auf, du darfst auf gar keinen Fall das Kondenswasser trinken, weil sonst, also da zwirbelt dir alles rum. Das ist wie wenn du in dir drin so einen Mixer hast, wie wenn einmal mit einem Löffel in deinen Körper reingeht und mit dem Löffel, wie so ein Joghurt. Du kennst doch den Joghurt mit der Ecke, haben wir doch gestern gegessen. So, da knickst du doch auch die Ecke rein und dann wirbelst du so rum. Und genau das gleiche passiert auch mit dir, wenn du das Kondenswasser trinkst.
Ich bin ein Joghurt mit der Ecke, mein Magen ist ein Joghurt mit der Ecke. Genau, aber die Ecke muss in der Ecke bleiben. Das ist bei einem Menschen anders, der darf nicht umgerührt werden. Und was macht die Ecke, wenn kein Kondenswasser getrunken wird? Dann bleibt die, wo sie ist, dann ist alles wunderbar. Okay. Pass auf, aber du willst nicht, dass du innerlich komplett umgerührt bist. Okay. Kann ich jetzt wieder mit Cockerich spielen? Natürlich. Du hast noch vier Minuten. Oder warum darf ich nicht nach dem Essen schon schwimmen gehen? Weil da, also wie gesagt, du isst ja mit dem ganzen Essen, da ist ja auch Wasser drin. Und wenn du jetzt noch ins Wasser gehst, dann löst du dich von innen quasi, weil das Wasser will dann sich mit dem Wasser aussen verbinden. Ah, okay, ja, das macht perfekt Sinn. Und dann diffundiert es so durch. Diffundiert? Was heißt diffundiert? Das heißt, geht durch, geht durch dich durch. Das zieht sich so nach außen. Durchgehen von Diffundare. Genau, und dann zieht dich das komplett auseinander und dann kann es sein, dass du platzt. Weil das Wasser sich innen nach außen zieht. Das macht Sinn. Ehrlich gesagt macht das Sinn. Gleiches gesellt sich gern mit anderem Gleichem. Genau. Das ist doch das Sprichwort. Das passt alles zusammen. Ich bin gerade dran an so einem Eckenjoghurt, weil es gibt manchmal so Dinge, die ich mir einbilde und ich brauche jetzt Antworten. Weil es gibt so eine gewisse Eckenjoghurtsorte, die esse ich gern.. So, jetzt ist raus. Den Joghurt mit der Ecke. Nee, es ist, möchte ich jetzt gar keine Werbung machen, weil ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Produkt das verdient. Und es gibt verschiedene Sorten von Ecken, sagen wir mal, es gibt jetzt Himbeerkirsch und Erdbeer, jetzt mal ganz weit gestreut. Und dann habe ich aber das Gefühl, dass der Joghurt, in den man kippt, auch unterschiedlich schmeckt, je nachdem welche Sorte es ist. Und weil manchmal schmeckt mir der Joghurt besser, weil ich löffel ja erst ein bisschen was von dem Joghurt weg, um danach die Konzentration der Ecke zu erhöhen. Idee. Je weniger Fläche, desto mehr Ecke. Und deswegen... Ich habe eine Idee. Alle Zutaten, die in diesem Joghurt sind, will ich aussenrum in kleinen Ecken haben. Alle Zutaten. Alle fucking ... Ja, wir sind langschüppelig. Stell dir einen Monte vor. Geil. Aber es ist eine Riesenschütze. Es ist nur Wasser in der Mitte. Es ist nur so ein Kondenswasser. Nee, auch Wasser ist aussen in einer Ecke. Und in der Mitte ist gar nichts. In der Mitte ist nichts. Weil du willst ja selber, weil du hast ja gerade selber das Problem auf den Kopf getroffen, das Problem ist nämlich, dass auch der Joghurt manchmal anders schmeckt. Du machst dir deinen eigenen Joghurt, in der Mitte ist es aber nur eine große Schüttel. Und du kannst auch die Konzentration sehr bestimmen, wenn du sagst, oh ich esse jetzt erst ein bisschen was von dem Zucker, mehr Zucker, dann von dem Geliermittel, esse ich erst ein bisschen was. Ich will keine Kuhmilch, ich will die Mandelmilch, hast du auch außen, eine Ecke an der Ecke. Eine Ecke
an der Ecke, du kannst in die, in den Milchkammer
was reinkippen, um das dann in den
Haupttopf zu werfen, das ist ja mega geil.
In Monta, aber du willst nur den Haselnussanteil,
hast du rechts schöne Haselnüsschen,
machst du rein, pfff,
und unten hast du so einen kleinen, musst du so selber
händisch dran drehen, so einen kleinen Mixer.
Das ist ja fantastisch,
das ist ja mega gut, du setzt es ja selber zusammen. Alles innen drin ist machbar, du mischst es selber. Es ist die Ecke mit der Ecke mit der Ecke mit der Ecke. Ja. Und du mischst den Joghurt in der Mitte auch selber, alles selber. Ich glaube, der Mensch will Individualität, der will das selber. Deswegen auch so dieses, ah, wie isst du Jaffa-Cakes, ich knabber erst außenrum in, dann lecke ich das Zeug raus oder Oreos oder so. Und deswegen sind diese Produkte beliebt,
weil man kann es zu seinem eigenen machen. Du kannst
da selber deine eigene Synchronie schlagen. Aber man kann es nicht
komplett zu seinem. Und da setzen wir an.
Mix it. Mix your own
thing. Das sind wir.
Oder der Joghurt mit den Ecken.
Wir haben das Produkt, das heißt
das Podcast-Ufo.
Okay. Mit der Ecke.
Das Podcast-Ufo mit der Ecke.
Mit den Ecken.
Damit ist eine grosse Schüssel.
Du kannst dir alles so ... Ich finde es perfekt.
Das finde ich richtig gut.
Und du kannst genau die Konsistenzen
genauso verändern. Und es gibt auch keine Reihenfolge.
Du kannst auch erst drei davon zusammenrühren,
dann zwei Löffel davon essen,
dann was völlig Neues mit reinbringen,
nochmal eine komplett neue Art.
Es sind super Zutaten.
Du kannst auch erst drei davon zusammenrühren, dann zwei Löffel davon essen, dann was völlig Neues mit reinbringen, nochmal eine komplett neue Art.
Du hast alles, was du brauchst.
Du hast alles, was du brauchst und jetzt liegt es an dir.
Es ist so eine Art Thermomix. Du hast so
wie den Pott, wo alles zusammenkommt,
wie so eine Art kleines Rezept auch zum Kochen lernen.
Eigentlich wäre das doch geil zum Kochen lernen.
Das ist der Slogan, wenn es scheiße wird,
liegt es an dir.
Ja gut, dann müssen wir vielleicht mit der Marketingabteilung nochmal.
Das ist negativ geframed.
Das ist ein bisschen negativ geframed.
Aber man könnte auch sagen, wenn's mega wird, gut gemacht.
Ja, aber wer hat jetzt als Alternativvorschläge sowas wie, du machst dein eigenes Ding oder Eck dir ein oder so.
Wenn's scheiße wird, ist deine eigene fucking Schuld.
Ja, weiß ich gar nicht, ob man das nicht vielleicht ein bisschen positiver formulieren kann.
Sei dein eigener Koch oder sowas oder Eck dir, Eck dir zusammen auf Ex oder sowas. Was für ein Loser schafft es mit diesen Zutaten keinen fucking Joghurt? Ich glaube, wir müssen nochmal auf Wiedervorlage, das funktioniert für mich so nicht. Wenn der Werber schlecht gelaunt ist, wenn der Werber in einem schwierigen Scheidungsstreit steckt. Eck von Schleck. Ich finde das super. Das ist eine richtig gute Idee. Sollten wir machen und ganz viele Ecken draußen haben, weil das ist doch das, was du willst. Die Leute wollen Ecken. Die Leute wollen Ecken. Ja, genau. Leute wollen Ecken und Kanten. Ja. Finde ich super. Machen wir, bringen wir den Start mit, wir packen das mal zu den guten Ideen, die wir hatten.
Genau, der ist noch aktuell sehr leer, der Eimer mit den guten Ideen, aber da ist jetzt auf jeden Fall mal eine Idee drin.
Ja, das finde ich gut.
Da ist mal eine, ja gut, das Giftfestival liegt noch drin.
Ne, das wurde ja gemacht.
Ach, das muss man, hat er mich noch rausgenommen.
Mach mal raus.
Dann machen wir es jetzt raus.
Dann mach raus. Okay, dann ist das Giftfestival jetzt. Warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, Immer wenn ich eine Mail verschicke, ist so ein Ja genau, warum explodiert die? Also was ist da, kommt die dann an oder kommt die nicht an? Ist das ein Zeichen, dass es nicht ankommt? Ich habe den Sound aufgenommen. Ich stand mit so einem grossen, so einem Boomer-Mikrofon. Wie heisst das? Mit dem Boomer-Mic, ja. Mit so einem Boomer-Mic. Ich bin schon ein bisschen älter.
Ich bin mit so einem Boomer-Mikrofon. Wie heisst das? Mit dem Boomer-Mic, ja.
Mit so einem Boomer-Mic.
Ich bin schon ein bisschen älter.
Ich bin mit so einem Boomer-Mic an die Startplattform von SpaceX gegangen.
Oh, okay. Ich habe es aufgenommen.
Halt da, wo es explodiert ist.
Den Sound habe ich jetzt nicht geschnitten mehr.
Warum? Also, da können Sie ja noch mal schneiden.
Nee, ich kann das nur aufnehmen.
Ich bin Boomer.
Aber ich bin so, aber verstehen Sie, ich bin Boomer im Sinne von, ich kenne mich nicht mit der Technik aus, dass ich schneiden kann.
Das heißt, jedes Mal, wenn eine Mail abgeschickt wird, zwei Menschen verstehen.
Oh, und erster Take?
Warum ist da immer noch ein erster Take mit drin?
Sie müssen das doch schneiden.
Ich kann nicht schneiden, ich bin Boomer.
Mit einem Boomer.
Ich verstehe zwei Leute diesen Witz, die in der Filmbranche arbeiten und schon mit so Boomer-Mikrofonen.
Ich bin ein, was ich bin Boomer. Mit einem Boomer. Es verstehen zwei Leute diesen Witz, die in der Filmbranche arbeiten und schon mit so Boomer-Mikrofonen. Ach, die Leute kennen sich heutzutage gut aus. Die Leute benutzen Worte wie Franchise. Die sagen, was ist dein Lieblings-Franchise? Das stimmt, ja. Das ist halt so ultimative Corporate-Sprech. Einfach so, ja, da müssen wir ein Franchise draus machen. Und plötzlich fangen die Leute an, auch damit zu sprechen. Früher die Leute nur, wow, ein Raumschiff! Und heute, ich weiß nicht, Sabo ist mittlerweile nicht mehr mein Lieblings-Franchise. Ja, das stimmt wirklich. Die Leute werden krasser. Wissen zu viel inzwischen. Die wissen zu viel. Reddit, ich glaube, man weiss halt zu viel über alle anderen Sachen. Haupt-Hater, ja. Haupt-Hater, nee, das Internet natürlich als der Haupt-Hater-Sales, klar. Aber man kann sich viel zu viel in andere Sachen so reinnerden. Vielleicht mal wieder abbauen. Vielleicht, wer zu viel weiß, kann sich nicht mehr wundern. Ne? Das finde ich superschön. Das ist so gut für meine Faulheit, dieser Spruch. Weil das sagt mir jetzt, ja, ich möchte mich ja wundern. Ich muss mich gar nicht mit allem beschäftigen, ich muss gar nicht alles können. Wenn du heute so eine Serie schaust, du denkst, jetzt sind wir gerade auf Seite acht, jetzt kommt irgendwie der Breaking Point, irgendwie der, jetzt... Man kann es nicht mehr genießen. Da war es so, du kannst es doch nicht mehr richtig genießen. Nee, deswegen gucke ich mir so krasse Arthouse-Filme an, die keinen erdenklichen Steu-Bogen mehr haben, wo einfach nur die ganze Zeit... Aus Versehen, die da teilfehlerhaft ist und rückwärts läuft und man es einfach nicht gemerkt hat. Wo fünf Menschen in verschiedenen Kostümen um einen Stuhl herumlaufen und das Bild ist natürlich schwarz-weiss, dreht sich um die eigene Achse, dann kommt ein Mann, der sagt, Sie können hier nicht filmen, das ist der Film, so ein Berlinale Experimental Short. Das ist ein guter Name für einen Film, Sie können hier nicht filmen, finde ich ich richtig gut. Und einfach nur eine Compilation davon, wie der Filmemacher rausgeschmissen wird, irgendwie aus verschiedenen Locations, aus dem McDonalds, Sie können hier nicht filmen, Berlinale auch, Red Carpet, Sie können hier nicht filmen, und das ist der ganze Film. Nur diese Szenen aneinander geschnitten. Und dann kommt im Kino, kommt jemand rein und sagt, Sie können hier nicht filmen, und der Regisseur setzt sich wieder hin und hat gefilmt wegen des Films.
Und macht die Kamera aus.
Und dann geht der Film raus.
Und dann kommt eine nackte Frau mit einer Posaune und spielt 80 Minuten lang denselben Ton.
Genau.
Bei der Band hinanlaufen, glaube ich, häufig solche Filme.
Ich glaube, da ist manchmal einfach das.
Wenn du dann irgendwelche Filme blind reingehst, hast du dann manchmal vielleicht einfach das. Ich hab neulich gehört, da wurde einfach eine Blume gefilmt und dann Insekten sich draufgelegt haben und dann sind die wieder weg. Gelegt haben? Gesetzt. Ich weiß nicht, es sind so viele Beine, es ist schwierig zu sein. Von so einer Biene, die immer so boah, äh, sorry, mörg, silly.
Das ist der beste Film.
Müde, müde Bienen.
Hoi, die Bienen hat keine Ahnung, dass sie gefilmt wird, auf einer riesigen Leinweite.
Das ist einfach nur, boah, fuck, war das weit.
Hoi, hoi, so Seitenstechen.
Seitenstechen, Flügel hoch, Flügel hoch, Flügel hoch.
Jerry, Flügel hoch.
Okay, oh, ich dachte, ich packe es nicht mehr.
Oh, der letzte Teil war echt anstrengend. Oh, ich werde zu alt, ich werde zu alt, ich bin jetzt schon zwei Wochen alt, du. Oh, ich will das nicht mehr hin, denn einmal... Oh. Okay, Jungs, weiter geht's. Okay, kannst du wieder. Auf geht's. Ich glaube, ich gehe wieder ein Stück. Sag sonst, wenn es nicht geht. Nee, pass schon. Ich werde es noch fünf Minuten nehmen. Ich halte noch mit mit euch, Jungen, du, kein Problem. Du kannst noch fünf Minuten nehmen, das ist ein Drittel deines Dreckslebens. Nee, pass schon. Ich werde es noch fünf Minuten nehmen. Ich halte noch mit mit euch, Jürgen, du, kein Problem. Du kannst noch fünf Minuten nehmen, das ist ein Drittel deines Dreckslebens. Nee, nee, nee, alles gut. Okay, weiter geht's. Okay, komm. Und das ist der Film. Das ist der Film, ein guter Film. Insekten liegen nie, ne? Insekten liegen nicht Schlangen die ganze Zeit, es ist da draußen das Wilder Westen. Ich finde, der Liegeanteil wurde sehr ungleich verteilt bei den Tieren einfach, dass man sagt, wir haben zu wenig Liegen, dann mach noch Schlangen hier. Dann mach Schlangen die doch die ganze Zeit, Raupen. Aber eine Schlange hat ja einen oben und unten, ne? Definitiv. Also ganz klar, der Kopf ist ja gerichtet. Hat einen Wurm auch einen oben und unten, so einen Regenwurm? Regenwurm hat weder vorne noch hinten noch oben und unten noch irgendeine Daseinsberechtigung auf diesem Planeten. Sorry, sorry, bin ich hart, ganz knallhart, zu hart, sagen viele, aber ich kann das nicht mehr ertragen. Das heißt, wenn du einen Wurm jetzt mal so um 90 Grad drehst, dann macht der so weiter, dann ist das eine neue Position. Der rollt sich nicht zurück. Der sagt okay zurück. Der sagt, okay. Flundern kannst du drehen und dann bleiben sie genau so ihr ganzes Leben. Die haben so wenig Interesse am Leben selber. Der hat keine Ausrichtung, der ist nicht gepolt. Doch, ich glaube schon, es ist einfach so eine Egal-Einstellung. Der hat so wenig Bock aufs Leben, weil er ein fucking Regenbom ist. Stell dir vor, du bist ein Mensch und du fällst immer auf die Seite und anstatt aufzustehen, läufst du auf dem Boot weiter. Das ist mein neues Leben. Und dann dreht dich jemand auf den Kopf und du läufst mit dem Handstand einfach weiter. Du bist völlig flexibel. Das ist doch Bullshit, oder? Es ist ein bisschen Bullshit. Es gibt doch bei allen Tieren Linkshänder. Das heißt, Würmer haben doch auch eine, der biegt sich lieber nach rechts als nach links, oder? Das ist doch, jeder hat doch irgendeine Lieblingsseite, oder nicht? Nachts, auf welcher Seite schläft du lieber, links oder rechts? Oh! Weil es gibt immer, man muss sich ja abwechseln, viel zu viel, man muss sich ja abwechseln und die, es gibt immer die schlechte Seite, wo ich dann kurz bin, aber ich bin da nur, damit die andere sich wieder frisch anfühlt. Ich weiss, wir haben kurz Spaß, aber, und ich bin ja auch gern, ich sehe dich auch gern. Du kommst doch eh nicht, um hier zu bleiben.
Nee, deswegen sage ich ja.
Du kommst doch nur hierher, weil die anderen keine Zeit haben.
Doch, Zeit schon.
Es ist nur so, es fühlt sich mit ihr dann wieder besser an. Ich bin doch nur ein Lückenfiller für dich. Ja, ich habe von vornherein gesagt, es ist keine feste Sache zwischen uns, okay? Aber warum kommst du dann immer und immer wieder? Weil es sich gut anfühlt. Es fühlt sich gut an. Und dann fühlt es sich mit ihr auch auf der anderen Seite wieder besser an. Okay? Wenn es sich so gut anfühlt, warum kannst du dann hier nicht schlafen? Weil ich mir das Schlüsselbein gebrochen habe und diese Seite beinahe nicht weht. Du hast ein Ausreden. Hau ab, dann geh doch zu ihr. Außerdem fühle ich mich sicherer, weil da die Tür ist. Als ob du irgendwas verteidigen müsstest vor irgendwas. Vielleicht doch, vielleicht kommt nach zehn Uhr rein. Mein Gott, du bist jetzt nicht Jason Bourne, hör doch auf mit dem Bullshit, von wegen, ich muss immer mit dem Kopf zur Tür schlafen. Ja, vielleicht kann ich doch reagieren. Ich hab doch mal diesen Selbstverteidigungskurs gemacht. Das weißt du genauso gut wie ich. Selbstverteidigungskurs, du hast mit so einem Schaumstockding auf eine alte Frau eingeschlagen. Ja, und? Bitte dich, als ob du so ein gefährliches Leben hättest. Du liegst den ganzen Tag im Bett, glaubst du, ich krieg's nicht mit? Du liegst den ganzen Tag im Bett und schaust irgendwelche Serien an. Als ob du jetzt irgendwie gegen angreifende Ninjas kämpfen müsstest oder was? Ich hab auch Serien geguckt, wo man irgendwie, wo Leute gekämpft haben. Ich weiß, wie man sich bewegen muss und sowas. Gerade du als linke Seite müsstest wissen, dass der Selbstverteidigungskurs schmerzhaft war. Allerdings. Und ich hab dir auch gesagt, es ist sinnlos. Okay, ich versuch's heute Nacht hier zu schlafen. Wirklich? Oh, okay. Das ging viel zu schnell. Ja, dann bleib doch hier, bleib doch noch ein bisschen. Bleib doch noch ein bisschen. Ach, fühlt sich doch gut an. Na, du lass mich ... Ja, nee, fühlt sich nicht gut an. Aber ja, kenn ich auch.
Man kennt es, man braucht eine Seite, um damit die Abwechslung, die andere Seite fühlt sich dann eigentlich gut an. Kennt man, macht man manchmal Dinge, die scheiße sind, damit sich andere Dinge besser anfühlen. Noch, beim Spenden ist es auf jeden Fall Thema, es ist auf jeden Fall Thema. Auf jeden Fall, ich meine, es gibt unfassbar unbequeme Schuhe. Oh, ich esse dann gerne zwischendurch. Ich bin kein großer Fan von Beilagensalat. Aber ich esse dann trotzdem mal gerne den Beilagensalat. Das ist ja ein kompletter Seelenstriptease heute. Also ich lerne ja Dinge über Stefan, die habe ich in unserer achtjährigen gemeinsamen Karriere noch nicht gehört. Ich bin ein bisschen verrückt. Du bist kein... Ich brauch den Beilagensalat. Sag mal, schimpfst du dich eigentlich nicht. Sag mal, was glaubst du eigentlich, wer du bist? Ich bin ein bisschen eine verrückte Nudel. Was glaubst du eigentlich, was du dir erlauben kannst? Ich weiß, ich weiß. Dass du den Beilagensalat verschmässt? Ich weiß, aber ich esse dann trotzdem manchmal gerne, damit sich die Hauptlage besser anfühlt. Klar, das ist der Sinn von Beilagen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Genau, manchmal auch schlechte Dinge, damit sich andere besser anfühlen. Ja, total. Oder du, ich trink jetzt koffeinfreies, zuckerfreie Cola. Das ist fast nichts. Das ist fast Wasser. Es ist fast nichts. Es ist Wasser mit Farbe. Und dann denke ich mir, aber eines Tages steige ich wieder um und das ist dann richtig gut. Wenn du dich daran gewöhnt hast und dann wieder das Ei-Iss-Zeug ... Ein Restaurant in meiner Gegend macht selber Cola, hausgemachte Cola, die ist fantastisch. Und jetzt kommt der Curveball durchsichtig. Die ist komplett wie Wasser, transparent. So wie Crystal Pepsi, das war ein Riesenflop, glaub ich. Ich glaube nicht. Nee, Crystal Meth war ein Flop.
Die Leute hassen, boah nee, in jedem Supermarkt lag es aus, immer Probierpäckchen, aber die Leute mochten es nicht.
Leute mochten es nicht, es war bitter, leicht bitter.
Nee, und das ist total weird, diese Experience, weil es sieht aus wie Wasser, es ist komplett durchsichtig, aber ich gar nicht verstehe, wie das geht, weil da muss man ja Dinge zusammenmischen und die sind ja nicht alle gleich Wasser und gleich durchsichtig, aber die sind ja komplett durchsichtig und dieses Trinkerlebnis ist maximal merkwürdig. Könnte alles durchsichtig sein? Ich glaube nämlich schon, alles von Trink zumindest könnte durchsichtig sein, ja. In Wein, Wein ist ja nur rot wegen des Farbstoffs. Aus den Schalen.
Das könnte alles durchsichtig sein.
Was für eine verwirrende Welt wäre das, wenn alle Flüssigkeiten einfach durchsichtig wären, wenn es einfach nicht unterscheiden könnte. Ja, vor allem beim Slush-Eis, die sie dann sagen. Ich hätte gern das das Recht. Funny Explosion. Okay, haben Sie es schon mal gehabt? Das schmeckt ein bisschen fischig. Wirklich? Okay, ich kann es vielleicht einschätzen, es ist schwer.
Fisch Slush-Eis? Ja, fischlich, sluffisch, finde ich gut. Naja, immer so herbe Sachen, mal herbes Eis, finde ich zum Beispiel auch. Also warum gibt es kein Rindeis oder so? Mal so ein Chicken-Eis, dass du wie so Eiscreme hast, weil es gibt ja Suppe, Spargelsuppe, die ja auch so cremig, sahnig ist. Spargeleis? Spargeleis, kann man das nicht einfach einfrieren? Warum ist das nicht okay? Doch, doch, in so coolen Restaurants, so richtig guter Restaurants, da kriegt man abends mal Spargeleis oder sowas. Man ist mir überrascht, dass es dann doch einigermaßen schmeckt. Lavendel-Eis hatte ich mal neulich, mega geil. Ja gut, aber Lavendel ist nicht, es kann auch süß sein. Lavendel ist, finde ich, neutral. Ist neutral, war jetzt nicht wahnsinnig merkwürdig, aber natürlich etwas, was man nicht so häufig isst, wahnsinnig lecker. Lavendel auch underrated. Vor allem, warum gibt es nicht diese, es gibt ja diese Gletscherbonbons, diese blauen, die schmecken nach Eis. Warum gibt es das nicht als Eis? Also warum gibt es diesen Geschmack, den gibt es ja nur in Bonbonform, nur Bonbon, warum gibt es das nicht als Eis, schönes leckere Eis? Eis-Eis. Eis-Eis. Also blaues Eis-Eis. Eisbonbons schmecken ironischerweise nicht nach Eis. Ah, wie schmeckt Eis? Eben.
So.
Eben, aber anders.
Die Leute, glaube ich, sind extrem enttäuscht, wenn sie Eis lecken, so einen Eiszapfen,
und denken, das schmeckt wie so ein Eisbär.
Eis ist erst mal gefrorenes Wasser.
Sorry, dass ich das so sagen muss, aber Eis ist erst mal nur gefrorenes Wasser, schmeckt
auch gar nicht kalt.
Was glaubst du eigentlich, wer du bist?
Aber Eisbonbons, man stellt es mal in der ganze Welt auf den Kopf. Mintig schmecken Eisbonbons. Ah, das ist schon was anderes, aber es ist ein ganz merkwürdiger Geschmack. Mir läuft das Wasser im Mund zusammen, weil wir über Eisbonbons reden. Zu viel Speichel. Riecht Bock drauf. Es passiert wirklich, wenn man Hunger hat. Warum? Weil der Mund bereitet sich vor. Der bereitet sich schon vor, der Vollidiot. Aber wie, dass gleich was reingeschoben wird? Ja. Und das ist dann besser, wenn er feucht ist an der Mund? Anscheinend einfach, das muss ja auch runtergeschmiert werden. Aber mein Mund ist ja nie davor. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass mein Mund trocken ist. Jemals richtig trocken. Naja gut, es gibt ja unterschiedliche Feuchtigkeitsgrade. Also so ein Croissant ist ja sehr trocken, so ein Handtuch ist noch trockener. Was ist trockener? Was ist das Trockenste, was es gibt? Ein Handtuch ist sehr oben. Ein Handtuch ist schon fucking trocken. Ja. Ich meine, ich bin auch wirklich immer heilfroh, dass wir in einer Welt leben, wo Dinge selbstständig trocknen. Also ich liebe es ja, Wäsche aufzuhängen, liebe ich. Manchmal hänge ich die auch zu lang auf, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, weil ich denke mir so, fuck, vielleicht können die noch ein bisschen trockener werden. Ey, wer bin ich? Wer bin ich jetzt zu sagen, dass die jetzt schon trocken genug sind? Ich gebe denen noch einen Tag, weil holy shit, irgendwas ist da noch drin. Aber wie gut ist das denn, dass Dinge überhaupt trocknen? Also dass, wenn wir Sachen aufhängen, die nicht einfach nass bleiben, sondern dass so das Normalzustand schon für uns angenehm ist. Wie funktioniert ein Föhn? Meine Haare sind komplett nass. Ich ballere mit dem Föhn drauf. Wird das Wasser, ist es A, das Wasser kondensiert, verdunstet. Das ist ein Unterschied, aber gut, ja. Nee, ich meine verdunstet, nicht kondensiert. Wie man bei A schon einfach völlig falsch abbiegen kann. Sorry, A ... Aber A kann ich jetzt schon mal ausschliessen, Herr Jauch. Also A, weil es überhaupt keinen Sinn ergibt, würde ich A jetzt schon mal ausschliessen. Naja, aber wenn ich den Föhn heiß mache, ist es in meinen Haaren, glaube ich, schneller trocken. Ja. Okay, aber dann kondensiert es, äh, verdunstet es. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Warme Dinge kondensieren schneller, weil die da wackeln. Die wackeln und hauen ab. Aber wie funktioniert Fön auf einer mikroskopischen Ebene? Wird es weggepustet, wird das Wasser von meinen Haarspitzen weggepustet, Richtung Spiegel und so? Ja. Oder wird es trocken durch die Hitze? Also ich glaube, du kannst es entweder also entweder rausrötteln oder halt wegblasen. Wird es weggeblasen oder wird es aufgelöst, die Feuchtigkeit auf meinem Kopf, eher beim Föhnen. Und es ist eine Mischung aus beidem und es ist genial, weil es heize Luft ist, aber dann dampft mein Kopf ja nicht. Und so heiß ist es auch nicht. Nee, es wird schon rausgeblasen, es wird dann trockenere Luft reingeblasen und die Luft, die fe ist, in deinem Kopf wird weggeblasen und durch trockenere Luft ersetzt, und dadurch kann wieder mehr verdunsten, und dann ist es raus. Und bei Heiss kommt halt jemand und klopft an der Tür und sagt, Entschuldigung, wir bräuchten den Raum, Entschuldigung, wir bräuchten den Raum, Checkout war um 10 Uhr, wir brauchen den Raum, Sie müssen hier raus, Sie müssen hier raus. Bei Airbnb stand elf. Sie müssen hier raus, Herr Wasser, Sie müssen hier raus. Sie müssen raus, jetzt, nein, nein, wirklich, jetzt, Sie haben keine Zeit mehr. Achtung, und, Sie müssen jetzt raus, okay, und raus mit Ihnen, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter, du nimmst den nächsten Raum, das ist die Hitze, die holt die raus. Warum sind unsere wissenschaftlichen Lehrvideos in der Schule immer so fucking aggressiv einfach? Fucking aggressiv Wir müssen jetzt hier fucking noch mal raus. Sie müssen aufstehen, sofort. Hallo, ich komm gleich rein. Ja, das ist die Hitze, die holt das Wasser raus. Okay, heute wollen wir, genau, habe ich das Lehrvideo mitgebracht von Gravitation. Hier einmal, bitte. Hier kommt das Lehrvideo von Gravitation. So, du musst hier hin. Hier, komm, runter mit dir! Runter, runter, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, kommen Sie sofort runter oder ich komme auf. Alter, du kompletten fucking Schaden, du Kasper, du kommst jetzt hier runter. Du fucking Spacko. Okay, du kommst hier fucking runter. Wir distanzieren uns von diesem Lehrvideo, es ist komisch, ist auch schon älter. Deswegen fällt der Apfel runter. Ja, sorry, das Lehrvideo war schon ein bisschen älter und irgendwie, ich weiß auch nicht. Wir wussten nicht, was ... Wir haben es davor nicht gesehen. Fuck, sorry, wir waren richtige Cocksucker. Wir haben es leider nicht ... Wir haben es leider nicht davor noch mal angeschaut. Sorry, wir waren richtige fucking bitches. Wir haben es davor leider nicht gesehen. Sorry, tut mir leid, wir sind zwei Lehrer, wir wollten eigentlich ... Wir wussten uns nicht. Du fucking Cunt, ey, du musst auch mal wirklich. Du dummes Fickerinchen, wirklich, also sorry, ich dachte, dass du es davor noch mal anschaust, aber wir haben es anscheinend nicht, sorry Kinder, wir haben es nicht noch mal angeschaut. Man müsste meinen, dass ein Unterricht mit zwei Lehrern besser funktioniert. Aber der Nachteil ist, dass man immer denkt, der andere macht es und dann macht es niemand und deswegen hat es auch Nachteile. Wir wurden zusammengesteckt, weil wir beide individuell nicht gut gelernt haben. Ja, nee. Und weil es zu viele Lehrer gibt. Und weil es sehr viel. Es gibt viel zu viele Lehrer. Das ist das Problem, was wir gerade haben. Wir haben pro Klasse drei, vier, fünf Lehrer, weil wir haben viel zu viele Lehrer. Okay. Und deswegen, ähm... Die Noten jetzt. Mirko kriegt von mir eine fünf. Eine fünf? Ja, Mirko kriegt eine fünf. Hä, Mirko ist super. Naja, ist ein cooler Typ, aber ... Mirko ist super, hier, check ein, Alter, komm, mit dem war ich's gelten. Mirko ist super, Mirko kriegt eine eins. Aber er hat nur Scheisse geschrieben. Mirko kriegt eine eins. Er hat gesagt, Gravitation ... Das ist Ehrenjunge. Gravitation ist Ehrenjunge. Er hat gesagt, Gravitation ... Oder, sagt man doch, Mirko? Was sagst du? Gottlos? Er hat gesagt, Gravitation ist gleich wild. W, Y, L, D. Gravitationssmash. Ey, Mirko smashed. Das war seine ganze Arbeit. Mirko ist ein Macher. Wieso kriegt er denn zwei von dir? Mirko hat's verstanden, Mirko hat's gecheckt. Mirko hat's gecheckt. Mirko hat's gecheckt. Mirko ist ein Wachstum. Einigen wir uns auf, was in der Mitte. Fünf und eins, was ist der Durchschnitt? Drei, vier, I don't know. Apropos Durchschnitt, hier ist das Video, wie man den Durchschnitt errechnet. Also nimm es fucking nochmal die... Ey, hör zu, hör mir zu. Hey, nur weil ich eine kleine Zahl bin, musst du nicht so unfreundlich sein zu mir. Alter, komm. Nur weil du eine acht bist und ich eine zwei. Halt dein dummes Maul, du kleines Dreckszahlahlen. Hey, was heißt hier Dreckszahl? Ich habe gesehen, wie du im Auto geweint hast, wie du auf dem Parkplatz im Auto geweint hast, bevor du reinkommst. Weil meine Drecksschlampe von Ehefrau meint, mein Kind dem neuen Drecksficker Patrick vorzustellen, hasse ich, okay? Ja, und dann musst du doch deine Aggression nicht an mir auslassen, nur weil ich eine kleine Zahl bin. Ich bin eine grosse Zahl und ich schluck dich. Ich schluck dich einfach, ich saug dich auf. Du kannst nicht schlucken, so wie die Flasche rum, die ich gesehen habe in deinem Kofferraum. Er hat getrunken, bevor er hier reingekommen ist. Du hast gesoffen in deinem Auto. Der ganze Kofferraum ist vor, da habe ich gesehen. Halt deinen Thomas Maul, du bist ein fucking Crackhead! Er schluckt mich! So, und dann nimmt man die Hälfte. Wir möchten uns noch mal entschuldigen, wir haben leider das ... Wir hätten eigentlich das Video noch mal davor anschauen müssen. Ja, wir hätten auch das noch mal anschauen sollen. Ähm, nee, aber ... Das tut uns leid. Wir wissen nicht, ob wir das Sexualkunde-Video noch zeigen sollen, weil ich weiß nicht, hast du es gesehen? Das habe ich mir als einziges. Ich habe mir das angeguckt. Sehr gut. Entschuldigung, kann ich mir noch mal das Sexualkunde-Video, kann ich mir das noch mal ausleihen? Das haben Sie doch gestern ausgeliehen. Ja, genau. Das haben Sie heute Morgen zurückgebracht. Genau, ein paar Kinder hatten noch Fragen. Wie Fragen? Erklären Sie das doch. Ja, aber ich dachte, es wäre vielleicht gut, nochmal Anschauungsmaterial zu haben, weil wir sind jetzt nicht ganz durchgekommen. Okay, aber Sie haben sich jetzt zum vierten Mal ausgeliehen, also ich verstehe es nicht. Genau, aber es ist ein gutes Video. Es ist echt lehrreich und ich komme mit meinen Kindern da echt gut durch und ich glaube, es ist wichtig. Ich meine, gut, es ist nicht klassisch Mathe und so, aber auch als Mathelehrer finde ich, sollte man das halt immer wieder Sie sind Mathelehrer? Ja, ja. Was für ein Bio-Unterricht. Ja gut, aber Bio ist Leben, Biologie ist Lehre des Lebens. Genau, Bio ist Leben, Mathe ist Tod. Ja, ich kenne das Motto unserer Schule. Wir machen Mathe und Latein. Da müssen Sie mich nicht daran erinnern. Sie machen Mathe und Latein. Alles, was Sie unterrichten, ist Tod. Naja, Latein ist auch Leben. Latein ist eine tote Sprache. Übers Leben. So, übers Leben, genau. Also ich habe mich noch nie lebendiger gefühlt, als ich Katolge lebt habe. Wir sind so lebendig, ich kann das Buch an die Wand werfen. Okay, alles klar, hier, dann ist das hier die DVD. Dankeschön. Warum lachen Sie so gräbig? Hey da, wie Sie! Ah, ein anderer Latein. Ein Kollegus. Eine Freundin von mir hat jetzt ihren Hund zum Hundetraining gebracht. Irgendwann müssen wir die mal einladen. Diese Hundefreundin, die immer wieder vorkommt. Die Hundefreundin hat sich jetzt überlegt, Hundetraining muss sein. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Die Hundeschule heißt Canis Intellectus. Und ich finde das so unsympathisch. Ich finde das so fucking unsympathisch. Aber was für eine Art von Hundeschule ist es? Die lernen dann so Jambus und Trocheus. Ich habe auch gesagt, gleich hat er das Latinum. Also am Ende des Monats hat er das Latinum. Aber er kann nicht sitzen. Der Hund am Ende einfach mit so einem umgeworfenen Schal und so einem Monockel, immer noch ein Arschloch, pinkelt immer noch auf dem Teppich, aber er kann jetzt Kartoll rezipieren. Der Docti, wie reicht ihm nicht mehr? Er will jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Wolfgang M. Schmidt Filmanalysen sich angucken, aber er kann immer noch nicht Sitz. Er kann weder Sitz noch Gassi gehen, gut oder ist nicht gut an der Leine. Er hat mich hier mit Stringtheorie zu und Quantensuperposition und alles. Ich finde das so falsch. Ich dachte eher, das ist irgendwie so Huldes Stöckchen oder sowas in der Richtung. Ich weiß gar nicht, wen ich unsympathischer finde. Den Hund, nachdem er bei Karnes Intellectus seinen Hundeführerschein gemacht hat, oder diesen, oder den Besitzer dieser Schule, der fucking Dekan. Weißt du, was du bist? Du bist eine Hundeschule. Chill, chill einfach. Ist cool, was du machst. Ja, wichtig, super wichtig. Komm ein bisschen rund um, es kommt ein bisschen zu viel. Oder irgendwie sein Support System um ihn herum, der ihm nicht gesagt hat, dass es ein scheiß Name ist. Ich weiß gar nicht, wen ihn in dieser Konstellation nicht hassen soll. Ich finde das geil. Karnus Selectus. Und was hast du heute gelernt? Naja, also wir haben natürlich heute auch ein bisschen was über die Besitzverhältnisse gelernt. Also eigentlich, dass der Mensch eigentlich gar kein Recht hat, Tiere zu besitzen. Also das sozusagen da, und da gibt es auf jeden Fall einige interessante Denker. Bruno, mach mal Sitz. Also wir haben da einiges von... Bruno, mach mal Sitz. Entschuldigung, lass mich den Punkt mal kurz so austreten, weil es gibt da einige interessante Schriften von Lassie, die da auch gesagt haben, dass da eigentlich ein Unterdrückungsverhältnis besteht, das so eigentlich auch nicht begründet werden kann. Weil letzten Endes natürlich der Hund als selbstbestimmtes Wesen auch selber entscheiden kann. Möchtest du die Frisbeeangen. Ja, ich will die fucking Frisbee fangen. Wirf die Frisbee fangen. Und halt dein Maul mit Strünke. Halt dein fucking Maul. Wirf einfach nur den fucking Frisbee. Und dieses Erklärvideo wurde ihn gesponsert von Canus Intellectus. Canus Stupidus. Canis. Canis, Hunde? Cani? Nee, Canis ist, glaube ich, Einzahlhund. Canis, Subsole, Jacket. Der Hund liegt unter der Sonne. Ach Gott, ey, das war alles so scheiße. Ich weiss echt nicht, wer bei euch der unsympathischste ist, der scheisse fucking Hund, der Dekan. Alles Hund ist ... Aber gibt es dann auch so eine Art
Frauchenabend,
wo dann irgendwie die dann aufgeklärt werden,
was so der Hund in der Schule immer macht oder so,
also wo man dann so Feedback bekommt?
Ich glaube schon, ja.
Also eher so ...
Der kleine ...
Ja, also wie macht der kleine Bibo sich denn?
Was ist denn ...
Genau, also Bibo hat
eine Mitschülerin gerammelt. Oh, was, oh nein, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, da hat er gar nichts von erzählt. Ja, ja, das ist ein Dominanzverhalten. Aber so richtig, also so mit … Ja, und … Und also was, was … Deswegen haben die anderen gesagt, wir müssen diesen Elternamt einberufen. Und genau. Wir haben gerade … Das tut mir leid, das ist ja unangenehm. Wir haben gerade Dante gelesen. Ja, ich habe … Das habe ich mitbekommen. Das ist auch damit durchgekommen, ja. Genau. Das ist natürlich sehr lebendig. Vielleicht natürlich mit diesen ganzen Gewaltverbrechern da in den Höllenringen und alles da und so, diese Sexualverbrechen. Klar, das ist nicht einfach. Vielleicht springt das, da müssen wir vielleicht auch mal überlegen, ob diese Art von Literatur passend ist für unsere Hunde. Ah gut, das ist ja einer von den Eltern, die uns jetzt hier lauten wollen. Naja, ich weiss nicht, das ist ja schon intensive Sprache, die da sante. Naja, nee, aber ich glaube, man muss ja auch irgendwo anfangen, wenn man da direkt anfängt mit von wegen hier die teuflischen Orgien in der Hölle und so. Das springt natürlich über auf die Höhne und Hunde. Das weiß ich nicht. Man kann es einfach als unangemessenes Dominanz verhalten und deswegen auch einen pädagogischen Missschritt ihrerseits interpretieren. Aber gut, wir schieben es auf Dante. Wie alle, wie alles schieben wir es auf Dante, okay? Naja, ich weiß nicht, also vielleicht kann man da einfach nochmal nachdenken, ob das nicht ein falsches Bild wird. Okay, dann schlagen Sie sich nochmal ein Buch vor, was wir lesen können mit der Klasse. Na ja, vielleicht können wir ja so ein bisschen Leberwurst auf so eine Fussmatte schmieren. Und dass das die Schüler lesen lassen, dass sie das so rauslecken. Fussmatten lesen. Ja, wenn da Leberwurst drin ist, dass sie das dann gerne so weglecken. Das mit dem Leberwurst machen wir ja auch schon bei Dante. Gerade. Auf jeder Seite.
Das ist ja... An sich funktioniert das ja.
Das funktioniert ja.
Wir lesen keine Bücher, das sind fucking Hunde.
Ach so.
Naja, aber die lesen es ja schon dadurch, aber sie brauchen Anreiz, um auf die nächste Seite zu wollen.
Ich verstehe.
Okay.
Ja, vielleicht muss ich selber Dante einmal lesen, ich habe es ja selber nicht gelesen.
Dante! Dante Alighieri! Ist ja der Vorname, ne? Ist ja einer der wenigen legendären Autoren, die einfach selbstverständlich beim Vornamen genannt werden. Dante, ist einfach sein Vorname. Plato? Ja, gut, okay, das kannst du dann sagen, aber einfach ansonsten. Nee, alle Griechen, also die ganzen Griechen, oder? Die Griechen Gang.
The Grease Gang.
Griechen, Greek Gang auf jeden Fall, aber ansonsten, ich habe jetzt letztens gelesen, das Kapital von Karl.
Was meinst du?
Von welchem Karl?
Herrn Karl? King Karl?
Nein, nein, Karl Marx, Karl.
Ach so, komisch, dass er den
Vornamen nur benutzt, also...
Ja, klar.
Klar, ich meine, ich habe früher viel Immanuel gelesen.
Wen? Immanuel?
Ja, Immanuel Kant.
Ach so, ja,
ja, gut.
Weil du den so gut kennst, dass er dann...
Ja, ich weiß nicht, finde ich einfach ...
Vor allem in Deutschland ist es auch schwierig, weil die meisten heißen Wilhelm.
Karl oder Fritz oder Franz.
Welchen Karl meinen wir.
Naja, in welchem Ring der Hölle seid ihr?
Wo seht ihr euch?
Wo seht ihr euch vor allem an der Woche?
Meine Frage an die Community.
Und vor allem ...
Also habt ihr vor, in den Ringen der Hölle aufzusteigen oder abzusteigen?
Wo seht ihr euch? Also wo ... Man liest das Buch ja und denkt sich, ach ja, siebter Ring. Oh, ich hoffe, das ist nicht was ganz Furchtbares. Aber wo seht ihr euch? Und habt ihr Lust, das noch zu verändern, bevor ihr sterbt? Und lasst aber Baby Steps. In welchem Ring der Hölle seht ihr euch nächste Woche, wenn wir uns wiederhören? Okay, Okay, ja, finde ich gut. Also, in Richtung ist es ja nicht wichtig, wo man steht, sondern in welche Richtung man sich bewegt. Genau, in welchem Ring der Hölle seht ihr euch zum Beispiel nächste Woche Sonntag zur gleichen Zeit, wenn wir uns wiederhören, also Montag oder Samstag wollen wir uns auch immer hören. Und dann möchte ich euch noch den Insider-Tipp für Samstagabend empfehlen, der Eurovision Song Contest ist wieder. Ich freue mich sehr darauf. Das wird eine Woche. Und ich freue mich sehr darauf. Und eine kleine Spaten-Sendung, die ich euch gerne ans Herz legen würde. Alles klar, es ist wieder soweit. Gut, dann viel Spaß dabei. Viel Erfolg an Deutschland und Österreich. Und alle angeschlossenen. Alle deutschsprachigen Länder willst du unterstützen. Ja. Und alle angeschlossenen. Naja, okay, so. Also, ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche. haut rein, viel Spaß bei dem und macht's gut. Haut rein, tschau, tschau, tschau.